Transcription: Marie Spitaels
Relecteur: eric vautier
Je suis né d’une mère kanake
et d’un père français.
Et j'ai passé le plus clair de ma vie
à naviguer entre les deux mondes.
À essayer de comprendre
ce qu’est le métissage.
Les premières années de ma vie,
je les ai passées à Montfaoué.
Mais c’est là-bas que j’ai compris
qu’il faudrait vite, très vite,
trouver des réponses à cette question.
Car c’est là-bas qu’un jour,
j’ai failli mourir,
mourir noyé, noyé par un cousin.
Mais bon.
Le temps a passé, je suis parti en France.
J'ai échangé avec le monde entier.
Je suis revenu et tout a été pardonné.
Je suis aussi revenu parce qu'on m'a dit
qu'on avait besoin de moi à la maison.
On m’a dit qu’il fallait construire.
Construire quoi ?
Je ne sais pas.
Ce qu’il faut aussi,
je ne sais pas.
Du coup,
j’aide comme je peux,
quand je peux,
où je peux.
J’aide pour apprendre,
pour prendre, mais pour donner après.
Mais on n’a pas tous eu la même chance
ces dernières années.
Dans le monde, toutes les semaines,
c’est l’humanité qui s’enflamme.
Ça brûle dans tous les yeux,
derrière toutes les têtes,
dans toutes les âmes.
Ça brûle la terre.
Ça brûle le respect.
Ça brûle les idées, ça brûle
le changement et ça brûle.
Ça brûle.
Ça brûle de savoir
que c’est encore chez nous
et que c’est la violence qu’on se partage.
Alors, c’est violence.
Violence parce qu’il y a
des tentatives qui ont échoué.
Violence parce qu’on se dit que
cette fois-ci, ça va aller.
Violence parce qu’on n’est pas
que des tentatives.
Mais la violence,
parce qu’on en est déjà là.
La violence,
parce qu’elle nous contamine
comme un virus qui nous asservit,
qui nous masque.
Et on continue comme si de rien n’était,
mais parce que la vie, elle,
elle n’attend pas.
Indépendante,
même quand on a trop lutté,
et rayonnante
quand on se sent découragé.
(Applaudissements)